Um, but my babies, that's where I'll be. Uh, and do you know why?
Because life rips, dude. You know what?
It always surprises me.
How much people like inspirational on Instagram or just period, really. I mean,
it's a whole reason why that place was, uh,
was able to be something in the mall.
Remember that place we'll call it whatever it was called,
like impressions or whatever the and you roll by it.
And it would have pictures of it would have the framed picture of a whale's
tail. And, uh, it would be like perseverance or whatever.
What the was it called? Doesn't even, it doesn't matter at all,
but I will tell you this.
I got my shirt on with my sunglasses on and a shirt with my face,
with my sunglasses on.
And the reason why is because dude I'm features too bright.
So where are your sunglasses today? Dude,
people cause people because let's be, you know,
let's because I'm inspirational, man. I'm inspirational, dude.
I can't help it. It feels good life.
I told you life reps and it does dude.
Uh, but it rips, but it's also, life is hot. So I'm going to turn the fan on.
Um, yeah, so that's, that's what that's what's up, dude. Anyway,
I got my sunglasses on cause it's so bright dude. When I look ahead,
I can't, I can't help it. I'm in Albuquerque.
I'm still back and forth and he's still back and forth in Albuquerque.
He can't help it because he's doing a movie.
He's doing a movie in a, and it's really fun and it's really hot. And the,
and the fan doesn't work. So that's great duty. Yes.
The fed doesn't work and it's plugged in. Oh,
because one fire kicked it out when he was setting up
the plug kicked out because when one fire was setting up it,
he hit it with his dumb shin. Yes, dude. Yes.
We're starting off hot and sweaty. Yes.
I gotta put this thing back in and then I got to start it.
Technical difficulties. Yes. Good thing.
My sunglasses are on, dude. I don't want to get cataracts. You understand it?
I went to the doctor the other day and I was like, doc,
what's going on in my eyes? And he goes like this cataracts. And I'm like, why?
And he goes, have you been out in the sun a lot? And I go, no.
He says, well, what the?
And I left and he goes like this, I'm at a loss. And I'm like, well,
what the do I do, dude? Usually the doctor's like take two of these,
come in the morning. But he didn't do that. So I got out,
I slept out here and went back to another doctor, got a second opinion.
He's like, I don't know what the to do, dude. I was like,
you're not going to give me two of these to call you in the morning, next time.
And he goes like this. I don't know what the deal dude.
And then they both called me a bout a week later and they go like this dude,
I didn't know who you were. I didn't know who you were when you came in. I mean,
I knew you, maybe you dabbled in comedy or whatever the, but then they said,
guess what? I know who you are now. And it's because you were on my TV and I go,
what? And I go like, yeah,
I saw caught in some stuff on Netflix occur in some stuff, you know, just on TV,
on network TV. Am I? And I'm like, he does network too. And I go eat and I go,
yeah. And he says,
I think that it might be the cataracts might be from your future.
Cause it's too bright. So now I wear these sunglasses and guess what?
The cataracts went away and not many people will
honestly make up a whole story on their podcasts.
That isn't true.
And tell it to you because you can go to other podcasts for the news.
You can go to other podcasts for interviews,
but there is one podcast that gives you a silly, goose time.
And that's it, dude. That is it, man.
If you're coming here for info, if you're coming here for interviews,
if you're coming here for other, other than a silly goes time and that's it,
then dude, as they say, you're in the wrong neighborhood.
One time I was shot at dude and that's real.
I was walking to a girl's house. This was so long ago, man.
I was walking to a girl's house. And when I got there, she was like,
it's a bad neighborhood. And I was like, it's going to be fine, dude.
Cause chicks are always like, it's a bad neighborhood and it's not, you know,
because their checks.
But when you get a real beefy dude with shoulders that they film Lord of the
rings on,
I parked two blocks away just to make a point.
I'm crossing over the street I'm taking, I, you know,
I parked parallel and perpendicular to her house.
And as I crossed the street, I hear pap. And then,
and I go, what the? And then I go, all I was shot at,
uh, and then ran man,
like a to her house. Yeah. Did we hook up? Yes.
Was extra good because I got shot. Yes.
Still in the back of my head. Was I sad? Yes.
That is still sport. Yes. Did she move? Probably.
She doesn't live there anymore. Probably not,
but I think about it every now and then. Yes, that I block it out now.
Anyway, dude,
splurting and bad neighborhoods is way hotter because you never know what's
going to happen to it. And we know that next. Why?
I even talk about that? Cause it's so obvious, dude. Um,
yeah dude. So you come here for a silly goose time.
And if anyone else tells you that you go to a nother podcast for a silly goose
time, bro, get outta here other podcasts and.
They can have a silly goose time,
but you come here for the real silly ghost time dude. Anyway, man, I'm chilling,
dude. I'm back in LA for two days to do this podcast
just so I can get it out there. And, and, and uh,
I did a show at the comedy store or at the laugh factory in comedy store.
And I talked about the cookie monster on stage for,
I don't even know why and it wasn't good. And it's.
Okay, dude, because alive or reps,
ah, for sake, [inaudible].
Just drank some water dude. But yeah. Um, man,
if somebody didn't like me and they heard this and they thought we know what
I'll give him, I'll give his podcast one shot and they turned on this episode.
They would hate me extra. I'll tell you that much. That's for sure.